is new Trek dead
and is there a dawn of a new track
but what would that mean for strange new
worlds and Academy
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
now that I've been talking to you for
the last few months that there's been
lots of rumors bouncing around that the
relationship between Alex kurtzman
secret hideout and elements of Paramount
is not great that there are big voices
in Paramount saying that actually a lot
of the new track we've seen over the
last few years has not really been good
enough and that they really want to take
it in a different direction and that
Picard season 3 has really just
underlined the fact that Star Trek is
still incredibly popular and a really
loved franchise
but it needs to go in the direction
similar to Picard season 3 to tap into
that love and what is that direction
slightly more let's say traditional Star
Trek now I have one source that I speak
to a lot he won't mind me mention it
that he he hates Alex kurtzman any news
information he hears anything he hears
he does put a very negative
anti-kurtzman spin on it he can't help
it he hates all of the new Trek now he's
been telling me for a long time that
they're going to go back to 2005 reset
that they're going to pretend that all
of this new Trek just didn't happen and
they're going to go back to the 2005
Ender Voyager and completely reset the
franchise now I keep telling him this is
not going to happen it's a it's a pipe
dream it's really is just the fantasy of
somebody that desperately wants that to
happen but just because we want it
doesn't mean it makes sense now
I've also argued with him that actually
the reset that he wants is already been
happening pecan season one started very
much sort of in the vein of how the
early Discovery started that actually a
lot of what happened in the JJ Abrams
Star Trek movies was bleeding into Star
Trek Picard the whole thing with the
romulans and the Romulan refugees Etc
this was a throwback from the James
Abrams movies remembering that Alex
kurtzman wrote a couple of those movies
but that whole JJ Abrams track
it isn't Star Trek they're good films I
enjoyed them but they're not Star Trek
for them to come out of the Calvin
timeline and bleed into the prime
timeline was not popular with fans and
also
this didn't really make sense it was
also very dark and very I don't know
quite negative in feeling in the early
seasons of Picard and in the early
seasons of Discovery what they call
drama I called quite negative and even a
little boring but Picard season three
you can't say that it is more like the
Star Trek we're used to it's a little
bit more light-hearted it's a little bit
more positive and even though there's
still drama and there's still action and
everything else it just has a tone that
is far more familiar to trekkies even
like in the ship designs Etc they
changed throughout the three seasons of
Picard to become something more like
what we're used to
in Discovery now I'm not a big fan of
Discovery I actually haven't even seen
season four I just stopped watching it
um and for me as I am a Trekkie to not
watch a Star Trek episode is just
strange I can't quite get my head around
it and even though Discovery is now
coming to an end I have to say the big
bits of the first two seasons of Star
Trek Discovery were very much influenced
by the JJ Abrams Kelvin timeline the
look of the Klingons is the most obvious
impact but actually in a lot of the
storylines ETC as well
and I never liked it but even through
Discovery you can see the changes
that the show dramatically changed over
its first four seasons and I think that
change will continue as we see a more
Star Trek Star Trek coming through the
reset that my dear friend who we talk a
lot argue quite a lot really once I've
been arguing has already happened
but instead of a sudden reset something
that would confuse fans and they would
have to be explained in some way we're
seeing a more steady reset they're
picking up the bits from the previous
episodes that maybe they didn't like and
they're just sort of forgetting about
them
but mainly we're seeing a change in tone
to the seasons I think the popularity of
lower decks
to really prove that for Paramount I
think the popularity of strange new
worlds even though we're going to
discuss that in a minute also has
underlined that fact but Picard season
three seriously underlined it now we're
getting stories at the moment about Star
Trek phase two
and what does that mean that it
basically is exactly what it says we're
moving into a new phase of Star Trek
Alex kurtzman seems to be quite excited
about this but really this is a phase
two there's something kind of forced on
him a little bit for one we're not going
to see as many Star Trek series actually
running together as we have to they cost
too much money but we will start seeing
these movie events apparently according
to Hollywood Reporter now these movie
events doing something every two years
which is a big straight to Paramount
plus movie I think is a very exciting
idea and obviously that's kicking off
with Section 31. you do get to speak to
a couple of people that are quite close
to Paramount on this and they've been
whispering again now a couple of months
ago I told you that there was a
marketing meeting now this marketing
meeting was asking for this company to
look at everything Star Trek and they
were putting numbers in cost to benefit
ratio basically how much does the show
cost how much does it benefit Paramount
Plus
during that meeting the executives that
were there started chatting to the
people from the company that had done
the research and they started asking
about Terry matalis and pacifically
Picard season three now when they were
commissioned to do the work Picard
season 3 hadn't come out so it wasn't
part of the research they'd done but
they were asked their opinion and in
those opinions they basically said look
we've already seen the numbers
increasing for Picard season three even
though it's not part of the research
we've been looking at it
there's a definitely different tone etc
etc and people seem to be responding to
that they're responding to the Legacy
characters yes but they're also
responding to the change in the way the
show is being written and produced and
presented to them Paramount have now
followed up with that and they have sent
out research questionnaires to a lot of
its audience and I've been able thanks
to again another subscriber to get hold
of one of those
um questionnaires
now it really does focus on strange new
worlds there's the bit of the first
question is below are some reasons why
people didn't enjoy strange new worlds
um tell us which ones are most important
to you and it's things like I find it
boring I didn't think it was child
appropriate it was too slow there was
too many characters to keep track of it
was not as good as Star Trek Discovery
it was it was much better than Star Trek
Discovery
um to politically correct
um and so on and so on
Discovery was just as sort of woke and
politically correct as um as strange new
worlds was
one of the other questions is overall
how do you see that these shows fit into
the overall franchise of Star Trek and
then it's got a slidy thing so strange
new worlds lower decks it starts does
not fit with the franchise at all or
fits perfectly with a franchise and
Discovery Picard and Prodigy are all on
that list so again that's looking at
there's a oh as a whole the franchise do
these shows new track fit in with them
many of them don't another other
questions is how do they compare to the
original Star Trek series again
and then it has a survey of what choice
do you like to watch
so you know romance comedies whatever
that
this really does line up with everything
that we've been saying and everything
I've been told by the couple of people
that I speak to and for quite some time
that Star Trek has been moving back
towards original track that shows like
Voyager Deep Space Nine the Next
Generation
they're moving away from the JJ Abrams
Kelvin line track
and I think as trekkies we have to
celebrate and we are reaping the rewards
but what does this mean for the future
of Star Trek well as I said earlier It
generally means the academy will feel a
lot more like in tone and the way it's
put together
the Trek we're used to
I am certainly I'll have a more positive
attitude and a bit more fun like strange
new world has
but what does it mean for Strange New
World seeing that this questionnaire
seems to focus a lot on
Parliament seems to be asking should we
be moving forward to Strange New Orleans
or not and they seem to be building
trying to get evidence on whether they
should or not now I do have a rumor
related to Strange New worlds that
actually it may not go beyond season
three now this is coming from somebody
that does actually work reasonably close
to the source he says no decision has
definitely been made but Parliament
executives are 100 looking at strange
new worlds and asking does it fit with
the phase two plan that we have does it
fit with what we want to do long term
and more importantly we only want one or
two live-action Seasons running at once
so what should those live action Seasons
be should it be Academy and strange new
worlds or should it be Academy and Star
Trek Legacy I'm going to talk more about
Star Trek Legacy in another episode but
it is really interesting that they're
looking very hard at strange new worlds
and that the third season might be its
last because then Star Trek Legacy could
appear on our screens
guys get into the comment so tell me
what you think about the idea do you
think that actually in Star Trek Legacy
deserves a shot but is there space for
it in the current market considering
that Paramount has to cut its costs this
is not about what we want it's about
what you think is possible
I'd also love for you guys to tell me
exactly what you think in this change of
Direction have you noticed it over the
last couple of years with Star Trek do
you think they are moving in that
direction and does this questionnaire
really just reinforce that fact please
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification it really helps
out and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack where most of
our new videos appear first and you can
watch them without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]